all right let's jump into the first
story we have this from 12news.com Lakes
expert witness misprinted ballots would
ultimately have been counted Lake's team
alleged that a ballot sizing misprint
disrupted the election but Lake hired
analyst clay Parikh says the ballots
would have been counted in the end I'm
going to pause right there and say that
is a gross mischaracterization of what
the witness actually said do you agree
Shane I agree it's just like how they
said she lost the lawsuit by having
eight things uh dismissed but two going
forward let me let me read a little bit
uh read a little bit of this uh and then
we'll explain they say Carrie lake has
two days to convince the Maricopa County
superior court that her election loss
was caused by outside interference on
the first day of the trial and in
information security officer hired by
Lake's team said that misprinted ballots
would have been duplicated and counted
no he didn't he did not say that Lake
needs to prove that a specific Maricopa
County employee interfered with ballot
printers and that lost enough votes to
cost her the election she also also
needs to prove that alleged ballot
drop-offs cost earthy elections Lake's
legal team originally planned to call
Katie Hopps to witness Lake even most of
the Katie hops will take the witness
stand all right let me let me just break
down for you what he actually said he
said that he inspected ballots they were
allowed to inspect I think was it like
50 ballon man's mail-in ballots and
standard belts or whatever and that he
looked at 15 14 of which were I was at
the 14 duplicates yeah and that the 15th
was torn right so all right so then they
said uh I think these duplicates were
these the ones that were 19-inch on 20
inch paper or was that he said most of
them were 19 and 20 inch paper so that's
a separate issue but here's ultimately
what I want to bring up with this so we
can start getting into it he said the
only way that the the image could have
been altered oh I got to slow down
because so it's it this is how they get
intricate it's right so you got a 20
inch image that fits on a sheet of paper
for some reason these ballots were
printed at 19 inches but on the same
size paper a 20 inch piece of paper
meaning when the when the ballot printer
was trying to read it nothing was in the
right place so
it doesn't read it it rejects it what
happens then is people place them in box
number three and then when they're
trying to count them they duplicate that
ballot what he actually said was The
Originals were missing that a duplicate
existed with no original to account for
it
then uh Katie Hobbs is lawyers Maricopa
County not Katie has Maricopa County's
lawyer comes up and says if a ballot is
duplicated as it get counted and he goes
that wouldn't be possible it's like I'm
asking you would it be counted and he's
like that's not technically possible
what the witness was saying is the only
way this error could have occurred was
not an air the only way this misprint
could have occurred is if someone
bypassed security and intentionally went
in and altered the printing mechanism
therefore in this instance it's not
possible for you to actually have that
duplicate ballot made and then counted
so now you get the media coming out and
saying well you know Kerry lake is
saying that they it would have been
counted and there's no issue here
my bet the judge is going to come back
out using this narrative that they're
creating and say there's no evidence of
anything and you know sorry there's no
intent therefore case dismissed the
defense sets up a sound bite that sounds
good in the news the news runs with it
all the nuances lost and like because
there's a ton of nuance leading up to
all that and they set up a witness to
say uh I think it was their first
witness I said it's impossible for it to
we didn't have any 19-inch ballots in
this election not at all and then they
obviously teed it up for that you know
bombshell I thought he basically said
the only way for there to be a 19-inch
ballot image on a 20-inch piece of paper
is if someone either manipulated the
printers themselves bypassing security
or manipulated the software entering
passwords or bypassing security so it
could not have been an accident what was
really frustrating to me about watching
this this uh this this trial is that the
the Maricopa County lawyers and Katie
Hobbs team or whatever they're they're
doing these questions where they're like
so Luke when did you stop beating your
wife it's a simple question did you stop
beating your wife yesterday yes or no
and it's you're like how do I answer
that and then the judge goes look it's a
yes or no question answer it if you
don't understand say I don't understand
and then they're forcing the witnesses
to claim they don't understand because
otherwise it's a question that draws a
conclusion yeah I saw I saw as them
asking them to prove the existence of
God in front of everybody because it was
it wasn't it wasn't simple it was a lot
of nuance and things going on like you
were saying it's so intricate how all
these things were happening and you
can't just say yes or no and it also
proves uh just how like convoluted the
chain of custody really is you know
they're very like reluctant to say yes
or no proves that to me at least what
really frustrates me is that they didn't
do witness training uh Carey Lake's team
you you you you have the witness and you
explain to them the opposing lawyers are
going to try to trick you I mean Kyle
you know all about this absolutely
they're going to try to get you to go
down this rabbit hole and they're going
to phrase things in a way that yes or no
either way you either way you answer it
it's going to sound bad no matter what
and that's what they do that's why it's
important for them to ask hey can you
please rephrase that question in another
way that I can understand it it doesn't
sound that it sounds a lot better if you
ask them to rephrase it but that's the
crazy thing I mean I feel like the judge
should be yelling at these lawyers like
you go up and you say something like did
you stop beating your wife yesterday or
the day before yeah we'll pick one which
one is it you're like what I don't beat
my wife right it's like that that's not
that's not responsive that's not what I
asked you that's crazy the judge was
getting impatient I mean there's a
certain point where it was hobbs's
attorney standing up constantly
objecting on grounds of foundation and
speculation and then they were like it's
all speculation this is what we're here
for literally yeah is that not
considered leading the witness when you
ask him a question with two pointed
answers that neither of which are
accurate I think that's a little
different when you're like I don't
really know but I think it's when you're
questioning expecting a certain thing
like you're leading down a path and
speculation is more just like the theory
behind it I could be wrong but like
that's because they they did get called
out earlier for leading the witness at
one point but the speculation was just
like because it was based on Theory I
guess there was a lot more as well
um correct me if I'm wrong but they had
a witness testify that 298 000 ballots
had no chain of custody I think that's
what they said yeah between like the
drop-offs and and I guess Red Bank run
back right which I tried to get into
Yesterday they refused you tried to go
there I was there I stood outside I was
trying I watched the sunrise over that
place wow it's like a walled off city
right by the airport it's a weird so
this this witness testifies that run
back employees were bragging about the
perk of being able to bring ballots into
their job outside of chain of custody
and have them be counted and the
craziest thing is not only that but that
there was there's supposed to be a chain
of custody receipt every step of the way
and there's one there's like three chain
of custody receipts and there's one
missing and they don't know how how
where these ballots came from or or or
what happened they just basically they
go from the from the polling look from
the voting Center then there's no
receipt then they leave the voting
Center and and they pointed out that I
think it was uh was it richer who
tweeted out 275 more than 275 000 bouts
came in plus yeah and then later said it
was 299 and so so she said obviously
it's a round number so it's not the
exact number but then with no chain of
custody he's basically said one number
and then added an additional 20 some of
that 22 000 23 000 ballots but without a
receipt we can't track where those
ballots came from the craziest thing is
the in the trial they're basically like
yes
we understand but can you prove anyone
intended to to break the law right and
Maricopa I think it was the Maricopa it
was Lindy who's tried being like so you
just so we make sure this is clear you
know it's not illegal for the ballot
harvesting to get in to this and she
came back with a pretty great response
she's like it's not unlawful it's
invalid she's like that's the proper
terminology that was that was I was so
we're you know we're all hanging out and
I've got the live stream going while
we're trying to eat eat dinner and the
the it was a Maricopa lawyer I believe
Lindy yeah Lindy he comes out and he's
like would it surprise you to learn that
if someone brings a if someone brings in
a ballot uh illegally the ballot itself
is not illegal like I'm paraphrasing but
he basically said if you enter in a vote
into the system in less than legal means
you may have committed a crime but the
ballot itself can still be counted or
it's it's not illegal and then she goes
I believe that's called an invalid
ballot she was really good this is crazy
I was really impressed with that the
corporate media's take on this is pretty
interesting because I just typed in
Kerry Lake into the news that's
happening on Brave and the first two
articles that are popping up talking
points memos number one and it says
Carey Lake big lie Circus Comes to court
the second article is by Newsweek on MSN
saying Carey Lake election trial married
with embarrassing mishaps so obviously I
mean this court proceeding is still
going on there's going to be another
court date tomorrow Robert Barnes has a
different perspective on this he just
tweeted a couple minutes ago Kerry Lake
proved everything she needed to today to
win her election contest that's what
Barnes is saying what's going to be the
decision here it's going to be
interesting because uh I think in 1994
there was a state senate election that
was overturned by a judge after there
was illegal ballot harvesting that was
ruled by him uh specifically in um in
the state election there so I don't know
what's going to happen here but this is
a very interesting court trial that I
think a lot of people have different
perspectives on depending on where
they're coming from politically am I am
I pessimistic to say I think that judge
is going to throw it out yeah
that's a form of pessimism you're right
I think I think that's gonna be yeah I
don't I do have hope because like I
think Barnes is on to something because
I I was impressed by uh not impressed
disgusted by the uh impressed and
disgusted by the like lack of security
the one witness is saying the ballots
were kept in
I I was losing it because the the first
witness this guy clay he said the
ballots were not properly sealed they
had no security seal on the boxes just a
piece of red tape and then the the
defense witness so this is basically
Katie Hobbs in Maricopa County goes was
the Box sealed and he goes there was no
security seal on it yes or no question
was the Box sealed and he was like it
was a piece of red tape yes or no it was
a box sealed and he's like I don't
understand it's like dude this really
frustrated me clay the answer is no the
box is not sealed they're playing a
semantic game they're arguing the
colloquial definition in a legal context
don't take the bait if you come to me
and say they could have wrapped that box
with Saran Wrap was the Box sealed no
but wasn't it surrounded with Saran Wrap
well that's not a legal seal so no it
wasn't sealed they're trying to trick
you because to the average person taping
something shut is sealing it shut right
that's the manipulation they kept doing
I was it's so frustrating we're gonna
show just those three seconds on the
local news and then that's what you're
parents are going to believe and that's
it and what they do is they're going to
show that clip then they're going to
give false contact context saying
despite acknowledging the boxes were
sealed the you know Carrie Lakes witness
refused to acknowledge to the court that
it was sealed they cut out the part
where he said they have tamper evident
seals that they put on boxes that you
can't remove without evidence of
tampering they did not have that they
were also like the defense team was just
I don't want to say they were scrambling
but it was obviously they had a
different strategy like it was like a
we're going to be forceful in trying to
discredit these people as quick as
possible right where it's like they're
set up with Nuance clearly with the
plaintiffs and then they just get you
know like a hatchet to the Head after
that and uh I'm like
it was they were so condescending this
might be just too personal but I
couldn't sit next to these people I was
sitting next to the defense team most of
the time they're just laughing like all
all these different times like the
attorney would talk like they just it
was like a very condescending thing like
let's have a little decorum here for
people you know like it's like when
someone mispronounces a word and someone
laughs at it it's like there's no point
to that to me it's like you're just like
just being rude for the sake of being
rude
um and they also have like just a giant
team it's like it's like when you look
at a pop song and there's like 30 people
wrote it and you look at the other like
a rock song there's like two people who
wrote it that's why I felt like I was up
against in this uh small courtroom in
order to bring the truth or at least
transparency on this do you just find it
was it was on video was this was this
court case I'm watching live you find
like specific little Clips cut them out
put them on Twitter make them go viral
that is that is that the way to move
forward let me let me let me maybe I
just wanna I just want to stress okay
you know I I I don't want to talk about
you Oliver Darcy but we're gonna talk
about you he tweeted out and there was
another journalist who did he was like
Donnie O'Sullivan of CNN may have had a
suspension lifted but he can't come back
on Twitter unless he deletes the tweet
and it's just everybody's everybody you
know in the anti-establishment anti-woke
was like yo did the lead media reporter
for CNN just learn right now how getting
banned getting suspended on Twitter
Works another journalist tweeted this
today saying Daniel Sullivan remains
locked out they're telling him he must
delete a tweet and I'm like is this how
it's been for like a decade and they
don't know this so the challenge is
you've got a combination of ineptitude
and willful manipulation from the from
the corporate press when Carrie we're on
stage at America fest with TP USA and
Charlie Kirk goes we just got breaking
news Carrie Lakes election challenge is
going to trial the whole crowd goes wow
they're all screaming and cheering then
I Then I then I'm like I got a fact I
gotta I gotta pull this up I pull up the
story from the local Fox Outlet it says
judge dismisses most of Carrie Lake's
lawsuit and I'm like what but she's
going to trial why isn't that the
headline that's a huge they got passed a
motion to dismiss
again I'm just gonna say I'm pessimistic
the way I'm hearing this judge you know
he's like
I it does seem like he's getting
frustrated with the defense attorneys as
well but I'm just kind of like I think
this dude is acting like you know I'm
giving them a fair chance and then he's
gonna he's gonna come back and say well
you didn't prove there was any intent
therefore you're gone that's how I feel
there he's offering leniency in places
where I didn't think he'd give leniency
like the plaintiffs aren't perfect like
they've definitely like screwed up a few
things here and there and a little
forgetful he that one guy is like like
Big Lebowski in a suit I enjoy watching
him
he just has funny phrases he has a long
hair yeah I like him um but you know I
don't think either side is fully
prepared just because they had like such
a short notice so you can see like
there's a lot of scrambling and
discombobulation behind the scenes you
can probably see a lot of it on the live
stream as well but yep but yeah they
they couldn't upload the the voicemail
recording and so the judge was like
we're not gonna play it and it's like
how are we supposed to get you this file
in like a day you know what I mean yeah
yeah it's a mess
hopefully I think people stay positive
and optimistic about it because that'll
generate the you know the energy needed
to continue to post clips about it and
to spread them around
you know what's funny though I talked to
a lot since I was there so early I was
talking to just like people who work
there who literally aren't engaged in
politics at all and just asking what
they thought and most of them are so
disengaged from it all together they
just I don't want to say they're like uh
they've given up they just don't care
and it's like in their very workplace
you know it's like ah whatever that's
crazy and and I'm also a lot of these
judges so many are just so far removed
from everything and to an extent they're
supposed to be the judge is supposed to
be like okay present to me the facts and
then we'll go through it yeah but what
I'm what I think we end up seeing with
so many judges and not just this case
but basically across the board with
everything is
they're thinking to themselves look I
don't know anything about this stuff I
don't want to be involved in this stuff
this case is so political everyone's
gonna get mad at me I'm just going to
tell them no one get out of my courtroom
and so they end up just saying get out
get out don't care don't want to deal
with it yeah that's a weak judge then
and that's too many of them yeah based
on what I've heard already
in this testimony I will I will say a
few things a witness saying there is no
chain of custody is not definitive proof
there is no chain of custody it is a
statement of fact sworn under oath and
now there must be the courts must seek
to confirm was chain of custody broken
that is an illegal action
if if the person tasked with with
maintaining chain of custody willfully
did not do that
then you've got intent and what they're
arguing though is uh what people have
called it is non-feasance as opposed to
malfeasance I if I was a judge I'd be
like get out of my face if you're a
barista at my coffee shop
and you walk in wearing your uniform and
I say you're going to stand here at the
register when that person hands you a 10
bill you will punch in their order put
the money in the register give them
their change and they go you got it then
the person walks up and they go I'm not
doing that that is an intentional act to
defy so if you have a a election
official and they are legally told
you're going to be here okay I'm
standing here okay now you're going to
count the ballots okay I'm gonna count
the bouts you're gonna felt this form
okay I'm gonna fill out the form okay
now do it no they intentionally chose to
break the law
based on that will the judge agree I
don't know so in my opinion
I don't know exactly how you Rectify
this because if you've got a witness
saying chain of custody was broken on
nearly 300 000 ballots that that of
course goes over the margin of Victory
with seventeen thousand and then you had
the last witness they tried getting him
they said do you have evidence that uh
the you know the vote would have uh if
if these errors if the tabulators didn't
break the election outcome would be
different dude actually said the margin
of victory was 17 000 votes I am
convinced that if the machine's working
properly Kerry Lake would be Governor
they didn't like that no they didn't
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time